we're here today with Laurie bier who is
executive vice president of specialty
businesses and information technology at
well point knowing - most of us do it's
BlueCross BlueShield subsidiaries Laurie
thanks for being with us thank you
Michael it's great to be here today so
Laurie in order to transform a
healthcare insurer do you also have to
transform healthcare providers and
healthcare patients in other words are
you somewhat at the mercy of things
beyond your control the whole value
chain of healthcare as we look at how do
we try to solve the problems improve our
processes we have to look at all the
other stakeholders across the value
chain I'm gonna start with providers
what we're really doing there because
we're the heart of reimbursement is
looking at new ways to incentivize
providers to drive high quality
affordable healthcare that's the number
one issue we have for consumers today we
also know that this industry has not
really had an efficiency transformation
and so really working with providers on
reducing some of the administrative
burden so we can all be more efficient
that's another key point as well that we
focus on from a consumer perspective you
know we really have a challenge most of
health care today is sold through
employers and so 80% for example in our
business is sold directly to the
employer and many times the consumer is
not even aware of what their health
benefits are or how to even engage with
them so we really are looking at that
issue and to end looking all the touch
points of a consumer how can we help and
engage a consumer many times today we
see that consumers don't actually engage
and looking at how do I choose
affordable quality healthcare what are
my options because first of all they
don't understand the true cost and they
haven't traditionally had to pay for it
so as we move forward we're really
trying to bring forward also the tools
the capabilities and embedded in a
process in a system that helps both
providers as well as patients more
effectively engaged in healthcare so we
can get the right decisions and choices
made so so as a as a organization
do the well point brands have to change
the way that they interact with with
providers and with patients is it
incumbent upon you to sort of nudge them
along or is there only so much you're
gonna be able to do in that process you
know from a provider perspective it
really is look working with them we have
to understand one of the problems that
they're trying to solve what will help
them drive efficiency many times for
providers today they see many many
patients they don't have a lot of time
one of the innovations we're focused on
is how can we bring together the data
and information we have about an
individual person and share that data
with them so that as they're looking at
the patient many times providers are
only one resource and the whole value
chain of health care that's seeing a
patient and so how can we bring them
better information how can we put the
right rewards and incentives in place
that if they help us in improving the
health of a member or driving affordable
quality care they have the right
incentives built in to support that and
that's how we really are partnering with
providers
you've noted that the healthcare
industry is in fact shifting from this
employer based operation to being
consumer based and that sounds that
sounds like a radical transformation can
you talk a little bit about what what
that actually means we are actually the
largest provider of individual health
insurance today so we do know when
consumers look at our products and
capabilities but as more and more shifts
in this direction it really starts with
how do we help educate you know we can't
just answer the phone anymore and answer
the question about the status of the
claim we have to be more of a con
serially pay all the bills
we understand that you know the pharmacy
the lab that claims where they've been
we know if someone's taking their
prescription it's not only information
that we would provide a consumer but
also information to their provider we
send actually health alerts today to a
provider that someone may be a diabetic
and has not had their annual eye exam so
that when that provider is having a
conversation with one of our members
they can follow up on those kind of
requests the other big issue though that
we're focusing on is people are starting
to use mobile technology to manage their
lives and you know there's been a lot of
health apps that are out there and they
get used and then they get forgotten so
how do you really connect it into the
system one of our most popular
applications is a provider finder so
today in that world they can look up you
know what is the highest quality with
integrated with my benefits provider to
go seek a treatment for in the future
you can think about it we can also embed
these health alerts I know I'm walking
into my providers office what I like the
latest health alerts that I can share
with my provider how do we help them
understand that if I need an MRI this is
the highest quality most effective most
cost efficient way to get that MRI those
are the ways that we're thinking about
engaging the consumer so you just said a
lot there let's unpack that a little bit
do you have to change sort of your
marketing approach and use new
technologies to get to these consumers
yeah I think it's really interesting
when you think about how do you market
to the
Zoomers that that were talking about we
we see this trend anyway and in fact we
see a lot more alignment in today's
business world between the chief
marketing officer and the chief
information officer it's so absolutely
as we've thought about our presence on
social media how do we get to a balance
when you think about health insurance -
and for it to work you know we need to
think about a balance of we need to take
care of those that are chronically ill
but you need to have a balance in your
pool of healthy people - and so how do
we think about supporting all those
needs how do we think about targeting
and marketing our capabilities to
support the individual needs of the
consumer and a lot more application into
social media and web presence and we've
thought about traditionally in this
business on a practical basis do you
find that you are spending more time
with the chief marketing officer you're
at well point absolutely for us when we
talk about mobile capabilities or web
capabilities if you think about that it
now has more of a marketing design
flavor on the front end design of those
capabilities and it is actually on our
chief marketing officer organization
that the consumer experience and the
connection of all those dots are coming
through one of the biggest disconnects
we've had in healthcare when you look at
the consumer experience is it hasn't
been connected and so we're really
spending a lot of time looking at that
end-to-end consumer experience that's
where consumer insights and research
work is happening and very much
partnering then with the business
leaders and information technology to
drive it more integrated solution for
the consumer traditionally information
technology has been a kind of sort of
passive partner or directed partner for
businesses because of the nature of the
transformation that's going on that's
really being forced upon all of
healthcare you know is this changing the
dynamic that you had at well pointed
traditionally we looked at IT more as a
shared service if you will I mean if you
think about our products and services at
the end of the day it's not like we're a
consumer products company where you can
put that product on the shelf our
products and services really are
supporting consumers providing
capabilities for employers information
data much more like a financial services
type of scenario so technology has
always been important to our business
but it really is becoming much more
strategic especially today when you're
seeing the emergence of new technologies
you're seeing a transformation of how
consumers are engaging with technologies
and you look at an industry that has a
huge opportunity to transform pulling
those pieces together as well as where
the health and the health care industry
really is right now
which of the technologies that are
emerging do you see is mattering most
for the changes that are coming in
coming down in healthcare there are
leading technologies in healthcare
that's great but one of the biggest
challenges we have is information and
data and so when you think about 80 to
90% of all data in healthcare is
unstructured traditionally our
capabilities haven't really addressed
that really well I like you to boil it
down very simply to say we're looking at
capabilities it is able to really sort
through massive amounts of unstructured
data and it's growing most of the
world's data has come up in the last
couple of years so how can we sort
through that you think about it from a
patient perspective especially somebody
that's chronically ill they're at
multiple institutions seeing multiple
doctors how do we get there single best
record and organize it so when I think
about our fundamental principles around
our key strategic imperatives around
affordability access to health care and
the consumer experience there's a
foundation of data that runs through all
of those components so mobile social web
those things are important
but some of the new emerging
capabilities around how do we structure
information how do we get to meaningful
insights at the point it matters to a
provider to a consumer those are the
things that are gonna really matter if
you think about the adoption of
technology and the delivery systems we
have to think about cloud solutions now
we have to work through privacy security
and those capabilities but that's gonna
be important as well you've been
involved with my point for quite a while
and you have a data-driven business this
is not the first wave of big data
it's just a nice clever name when you
are talking with your fellow executives
about this you know how much skepticism
do you have to overcome and how do you
manage their expectations about what you
can do and and I guess a third question
is what's different now so there's a lot
of questions packed in there and I'll
unpack it for you one by one starting
with you know we have talked about data
in our business for a long period of
time but the way we've thought about it
has been more in a traditional sense how
do I get to
making sure and looking at data that I
understand operationally that I'm paying
my claims on time and those kind of
things what's not just new to our
industry but what you see emerging in
business in general is how do you use
data and information to look at your
business differently and have actionable
insights as to how I might think about
the products and services that are
really going to make a difference how I
might think about differently when I had
an opportunity to run operations for a
while we really turned that upside down
we didn't look at some of the original
service metrics average speed of answer
and things like that
we focused on why were customers having
to call us back how do we really take
the rework out of the system in the
process what leading indicators could we
see in claims coming through that we
hadn't traditionally looked at those are
ways that were thinking about so part of
it is and that you know what you have to
face is a challenge not only in our
business and industry but on others too
is you have to look at your business
differently you have to think about the
problem that you're trying to solve and
you have to work with the business very
proactively to understand many times the
technology organization can understand
the potential of technology we have to
align with the business to understand
that we're truly meeting their needs at
the end of the day so when you look at
unstructured data I think you gave up
perhaps a small it started to give an
example of you know what I think would
be an unstructured data problem why are
people calling in it is that an example
of the kind of shift you're talking
about with this move to sort of looking
at unstructured data and what it can do
for you
you know certainly there are
opportunities and looking at
unstructured data to understand how we
can better service a member there's a
lot of other data you know a lot of
times traditionally we've looked at
healthcare data and trying to provide
the best service to an individual we
really know that the behavioral element
is so important and understand if
someone's going to remain compliant with
taking their medication or how they may
react to new drugs and treatments etc
and so part of what we're actually
trying to do too is on the consumer
front is looking at other
information we haven't traditionally
looked at would have then been their
general patterns as a consumer that's on
that side the bigger lever here is when
you think about real true cost in health
care is how do we get at the
unstructured clinical information if you
think about what our nurses receive
today when we're trying to authorize a
treatment or you know and partner with
physicians around that multiple pages of
unstructured medical notes and
information but the bigger value
ultimately when we think about driving
affordable quality health care is
getting our arms around all this
unstructured data more on the clinical
side of things so and and practically
speaking how does that drive change so
does that for instance let you look at
certain kind of patients and or and and
then tell them you should be seeing this
kind of person you shouldn't be seeing
that kind of specialist or does it
conversely allow you to look at a
hospital system health care provider
that's looking at teen care combining
physician's assistants and registered
nurses and pharmacists and doctors and
not necessarily having the patients see
the doctor very often there's a way to
kind of cut cost yeah I think there's
multiple perspectives on this one is
from a consumer a patient's perspective
you know it's really important that we
support them in their care and not
dictate you know what doctors they
should see but many times when they call
us and ask us who should they go see a
specialist etc how do we give them the
best information around whether it's
feedback from a consumer or those that
have better quality results for the
particular situation of the individual
the other thing we have to keep in mind
here is that medicine is becoming much
more personalized especially even in
oncology and cancer care some of those
some of those areas but that's going to
continue to explode over time as well
too so when they call us to ask for that
information how do we help direct in the
payment innovation side with the
provider as we're looking at those new
reimbursement models this is really
important how do we give providers data
on how things you know how they're
performing in in terms of managing their
population what are some ideas some of
the health alerts that we could give
them on their member population we are
all equally aligned that if they can
help drive the best
health care in the incentive based
reimbursement models everybody wins so
this is where the paradigm is changing
how can we provide information can you
just talk about whether you've you're
seeing signs that it will help reduce or
slow costs I mean the u.s. spends you
know fifty percent more of its GDP on
health care than any other developed
country for instance yeah we are seeing
signs certainly that that can change in
all of our pilot studies we were so
confident that it can move the needle
that now we are doing this broadly in
something we're called calling patient
centered primary care across the
enterprise where we're actually
incentivizing primary care doctors to do
things that we traditionally haven't
paid for care management plans maybe
email visits some of these web visits
that we're going to talk about because
we can see that if we can incentivize
them to more actively engage not in that
visit that that that few minute visit
they have with that member but in the
overall health of a member they win as
well as we believe the patient wins in
the end can you kind of unfold that
across your units all at one so do you
have to kind of go unit by unit and a
negotiation process and yeah you know
when we when we looked at this issue
it's well-documented that there's for
payment innovation people have done
pilot a ce o--'s accountable care
organizations or pilant patient-centered
medical homes we actually made a pretty
bold statement that we're out of pilot
mode and we're really going to roll this
across the country in all of our markets
that does mean that our local teams on
the ground that work with the delivery
systems hospitals doctors etc have to
have those conversations around how do
we get things aligned from a
reimbursement perspective and that is
happening broadly as we speak today and
we just in January started rolling out
our first capabilities and they're
staged because part of what goes along
with that is not the agreement just on
the reimbursement piece but we're
rolling out reports and data and
information and and even more technical
capabilities this longitudinal patient
record over time so again they have that
single best record of our data bringing
together their
as well those are some of the more
advanced capabilities that are coming
the first commercial adopter of Watson
and that's also out of pilot mode so
tell us how did the Watson project come
about
I really believe innovation in this
industry is not going to just come from
what we can do we have to make it work
across the whole value chain we have to
work with other partners to do that so
it really started with a foundational
perspective that we work really well
with IBM today their great partner and
in this case actually had the
opportunity to be on the set of the
taping of Jeopardy and so you know I
really believe that day when you looked
at how Watson played jeopardy
it demonstrated this new age of
cognitive computing that is so relevant
you know you talked to one of our
doctors who has been involved in the
Watson work when they he thought about
how Watson was playing jeopardy he said
that's how I think about treating a
patient I look at lots of our options
and I always try to bring forward that
recommendation on diagnosis or treatment
based on the data I have and what I
believe is the highest likelihood that
that situation is correct and so it
really started from the perspective of
the demonstration of the new technical
capabilities it started on a sound for
solid foundation of partnership we
actually then went to IBM we weren't the
only ones interested we actually had to
sell ourselves kind of an interesting
paradigm you turn it upside down but if
you think about the deep market share we
have in our local markets the ability to
align it with our reimbursement
strategies it's not about just putting
new tools and capabilities in has to
work in the system and that's really how
we started the foundational of this
partnership how did you sell yourself to
IBM well part of it was understanding
the reach that we have right so we
provide healthcare benefits to 36
million Americans that's one in nine
Americans and when you look across all
Blue Cross Blue Shield plans it's one in
three Americans so as a Blue Cross Blue
Shield plan we have very deep reach but
it's also that density in the local
market how can you really move a market
part of that is being able to have that
that local Dennis density was also a
commitment from the top we flew our
executive team there to sit down and
have the conversations because something
like an innovation like Watson we're
literally
taking out of we were not only the first
ones in health care we were the first
ones in any industry if you don't have
that alignment at the top of the
organization you're not going to be
successful and this was a new concept
for us but when you think about the the
big challenges we're trying to solve
it's gonna take new innovations to be
able to do that and so that's really how
we you know got the support we had to
get the support at the top both from IBM
and wellpoint and we started our journey
so did you have you know a cognitive
computing specialists on staff how do
you find these people to to bring this
to life inside your Co this is what's
been really great about the partnership
you know one of the nurses that have
been involved with us from day one she
actually will say you know she started
her nursing career not even using any
technology and now she thinks it's you
know phenomenal that she's training
technology to help her do her job so
really the unique partnership here is
not that we had to build all the
expertise but that we aligned incentives
across IBM and WellPoint it is really
gratifying when you see someone like
that one of our nurses or doctors our
clinicians working side-by-side with the
IBM engineers that are helping tune
Watson so the piece that we bring to the
table is the deep elf care knowledge the
ability to understand if Watson's not
gotten the answer right what's the
association and health data that's
different than what Watson had to be
trained to play jeopardy and that's been
that teaching process that we've been
going through so it's really a unique
partnership that we're bringing the core
strengths that they have to the table
we're bringing our core strengths we
have aligned incentives and that's how
we're working on delivering the solution
and so does it does it sort of sit in in
the cloud someplace at IBM do you have
it are you hosting it we signed the deal
back in September of 2011 and by
December of that year we had a baby
Watson stood up in our data center in
Richmond Virginia that quick and we
actually had an application that was
doing round-trip transactions so we
really accelerated from the point in
time because you have to put it through
a teaching process as we thought now to
the commercialization or industrializing
it we are actually using
acting now our production version is
actually connecting to Watson that's
what in one of IBM Smarter Data Center
capabilities and that's a better
approach when did you know it was
working here's clinicians working on
this every day that to some extent will
change their jobs and you know but when
we looked at the data forty to sixty
percent of our clinicians time was spent
on organizing and looking up information
we want them to spend their time on
clinically thinking through what's best
for our members what's best for our
patients for me what matters is not when
I believe the technology could work
because you know I have a technology
background and I was pretty confident
when we first started this journey that
we would ultimately make it work is when
the nurse said to me said you know to me
that she actually put information in in
Watson gave back the right answer
then she knew it was a lightbulb moment
and this was actually going to be able
to work in healthcare so are you sure
yet that it's going to be transformative
I do believe it's going to be
transformative I think you know we are
seeing great promise and now we took it
actually out of the innovation R&D mode
and it's actually embedded into our core
care management strategy so I know for
that piece of work it's definitely going
to work because we've seen enough
promise the other really exciting thing
if you think about artificial
intelligence and a traditional decision
support type system every new procedure
we would present it with you'd have to
program that procedure to work right
it's structured you know language if you
think about what we just did this was a
breakthrough we had in the last couple
of weeks we presented two brand new
procedure codes to Watson that Watson
had never seen and Watson achieve the
accuracy without any further teaching so
that tells you that we have made
progress in the training of Watson truly
understanding healthcare and how to
relate unstructured healthcare
information I think what to me it's more
the challenge because this is this is
tough work the challenge is more how
fast and in what scenario so to me it's
not an issue of will Watson work or not
where are we going to find the most
value with this new technical cape
ability and where do you see Watson
having the the biggest impact is it your
operations is it for health care
providers is it for patients I think in
the short term we're certainly seeing
the efficiency as I mentioned because
forty to sixty percent of our clinicians
time was set on suspend on just
aggregating and collecting information
to be able to make their decision
you're certainly going to see an
efficiency factor I think the
longer-term value is if you look at the
work we're doing with IBM and Memorial
Sloan Kettering and oncology and you
think about the massive amounts of new
insights and research that are coming
out the ability to put at a clinicians
you know in front of them the leading
research really tied together with a
single best record of my information to
be able to match those two together and
bring recommendations back to the
physician who's ultimately making the
decision this is a tool that I think on
the driving the affordable cost of
healthcare and really moving the needle
on looking at you know many times today
physicians are trying to eliminate its
particular conditions so the order of
battery attests with more intelligence
how can we even narrow down one of the
things that we envision is Watson can
actually say I'm fifty percent confident
it may be this but if I have this data I
could be 75 percent confident and so I
really think we're gonna see the bigger
impact is going after this how do we
drive affordable quality quality
healthcare
how much of your time would you say you
you're able to spend on things that you
think are gonna be transformative I
would say in my role it's probably 60%
of my time how do you decide what to
focus on for instance you're obviously
ahead of everybody else with Watson but
you know some of some other health
insurance have sure's have looked at you
know telemedicine pretty heavily are
doing more with live video consult it
starts with our mission improve the
lives of the people we serve the health
of our communities so that's the
grounding the three strategic
imperatives we've really tried to
simplify affordability as number one if
we're not looking at things that are
really moving the needle and
affordability we believe that's our
responsibility and that is number one
priority it's a big issue not only for
the consumer when you look at median
income over an average household over
the last eight years to stay the same
health care costs have doubled we have
to address this issue it's an issue for
our country 18% going to 20% GDP
number-one focus very clear affordable
quality health care access big issue
there's issue with access today less
than 50% of prime doctors are accepting
new patients so we're seeing that now we
see as we talked about earlier with
healthcare reform more people coming
into the system how do we make sure so
we're at that tipping point where access
is going to become an even bigger issue
which is why you're seeing it becoming
more embedded into our strategy and
number three is consumer experience and
that's the other one you know how do we
really engage the consumer into this
equation we actually have been doing
telemedicine for several years we
actually started pilots in California
very early on what's different this time
is we're thinking about going back to
what I talked about earlier it's not
just about having a telemedicine
capability it's about how does it tie
into and so when we're doing our work
with live health online now it's very
much focused on how's it integrated with
my benefits so that it's not something I
go and have to pay out of my pocket but
it's integrated with my benefit solution
how do we make sure it's more that
experience many of the telemedicine type
scenarios you place a phone call ours is
very immersive online doctor visits much
more consumer experience when we bring
up that telemedicine visit with life
health online
as my patient record so we're really
trying to connect all the pieces
together which is now while you're
hearing us talk more about it because
it's more directly aligned with our
strategy well it sounds like all so what
you're saying is that to do something
transformative is not something where
you snap your fingers and suddenly
everything has changed yeah one of the
things and in telemedicine is a great
one a lot of times companies look at
that because it's a capability I can
sell to an employer the way I think
about it is if it doesn't work for the
consumer and the providers the the
solutions not going to work for the
long-term so in that scenario absolutely
we had to think and understand how do
you make it work so the doctors will be
available online and so when you think
about the payment innovation we talked
about earlier where we're supporting
them through reimbursement to do these
kind of visits you know that's an
important important factor if I as a
consumer go into this model and I don't
have a great experience again it won't
matter
you know in the end if you can't make
the whole system work for employers for
consumers for providers the other thing
I would say is we as we look at
innovation I would say that kind of more
generally we try to bucket it there's
normal innovation that happens in your
product lifecycle you all we always have
to think about how do you get new
products to market how do you how do you
do process improvement that's one type
we also try to look at innovation from
the context of how does it drive
long-term value and how is it tie back
to your strategy that's really important
there's some game changers and I would
put Watson in that game change your
bucket but we have to focus on just a
few of those and there's other
opportunities where you can partner with
a company such as what we're doing with
live health online for the telemedicine
type solution and then there's also
companies we put an investment in so we
can get first to market on new
capabilities so we really try to look at
the various forms of innovation and
understand you know you can only make a
few big bets but you can do innovation
in many other ways embedded throughout
your business and drive a lot of value
to your company so what would you say
besides Watson know your big game
changers we have this issue electronic
medical records really aren't moving the
needle if you go back to this issue
about the amount of data
that we have and just to give you some
context we have health data on a hundred
million unique individuals from various
points in time right even though we have
36 million health members today and if
you think about our enterprise data
warehouse so we do have Big Data right
we it's bigger than the size of what's
stored in the Library of Congress we
have focused our innovations on how do
we collect and organize all the
information about me not as a member of
a health plan but as an individual
person my daughter went to the
pediatrician had some issues on her her
local tests we had a sender to
Children's Hospital what did I do when I
first got there I had to give all of her
background or history documental that it
was things that we have documentary
history the story that goes on is that
as the pediatrician was calling me to
say call me Monday I was assuming I was
getting the health results having worked
in this industry I simply said to
Children's Hospital do you have an
electronic medical record and can I get
access to the information which I did so
by the time I left Children's Hospital
and got home I had my daughter's lab
results and I pretty much could self
diagnose what the issue was going on and
she had iron deficiency anemia I called
my doctor Monday morning only to tell me
that they were waiting to hear from
Children's Hospital and we're waiting
for the lab results at which to I said
have them would you like them my point
in this simple example is we have to
help facilitate the integration of
information to get people to care they
need in this what we call a longitudinal
patient record I think it's a really
important innovation we'll do mobile
we'll do social we'll do all those kind
of things but you know Watson that can
help us sort through massive amounts of
information unstructured data ability to
aggregate information and if you think
about it as we're talking about new
reimbursement mechanisms part of that
discussion is what data ours and
providers do we need to start bringing
together and does that mean for instance
if your daughter ends up say working
someplace where a WellPoint company
isn't insurer and she's had WellPoint
subsidiaries as
sort of insurer prior to that time where
does that data go this is actually an
issue we're working through now because
as we've started to expose some of our
hospitals physicians to the information
that we have the first question that
comes up is can I have that for all my
patients and so we're actually thinking
through how to think about that model
going forward and and how do we really
make sure you know for us this has to be
a cloud-based solution but obviously
that's something that over time we have
to really think through and do you have
to build that yourself is that not clear
yet we don't have to build the
capabilities ourself in this case we're
really bringing integrating technologies
together and bringing a solution forward
but I believe you know it has to be a
cloud solution it's been really
challenging for delivery systems to
implement electronic medical records
their resources are generally very thin
how do we make something simple to get
access to that's going to be important
as well
so in a place like Microsoft smart house
of the future where you've got sensors
that are feeding data about the
environment and about the people in the
environment to to different systems be
interpreted are those the kinds of
things that will also become
transformative and will then feed into
the data that you're that you want to
gather or that a patient is going to
have what happens with those and do they
transforms things transform things or
are they just sort of nice little
research experiments everything is
becoming censored everything's becoming
wired these days and generating lots of
information I think the key point around
this goes back to I absolutely believe
for it to work it has to naturally fit
into the consumers world right and so I
really think over time we've had
monitoring devices out there for some
time
why haven't they gotten adopted
sometimes it's a challenging to use them
and plug them in technology keeps
getting smaller and smaller it's a
smores law thing and processing faster
and when you start to think about the
capabilities some new innovations that
are starting to emerge an EKG that's
really a case that fits over your
smartphone I mean I've tried it it works
fantastic you know those kind of things
it's not something different I have my
smartphone how can i how can we fit into
those kind of things that's what I like
about telemedicine you know what's
taking the doctor where the consumer is
is the consumers in their home I think
there's lots of information we can think
about we actually do some of this today
in a subsidiary we have called care more
that really focuses on that Medicare
Advantage and we actually have those
seniors actively manage their weight and
we can see that if there is a rapid
increase in weight gain within a
particular day
someone needs to reach out to them
because they may have an accelerating
health condition that we want to
intervene before they end up in the
emergency room but it's got to be simple
and it's got to fit into the consumer
world we have to keep thinking about the
design because that I think is
ultimately what's going to drive the
engagement with a consumer what are the
biggest obstacles organizationally to
transforming your operations I think
this is one of the most transformational
times we'll ever see in this business
and our industry has been slower to
transform I think and a lot of things
have been tried in healthcare so I think
for the industry in general and also
some of the challenges we face is you
know not making sure that we're not
looking at things based on where we've
been but where the market is going and
also making sure we're not just paying
attention to what's happening in our
industry I think there's a huge
intersection as I mentioned earlier with
what consumers are expecting how they're
engaging with technology we have to
capture that I just want to throw a
chronic care question at you in our last
couple minutes here so chronic care
accounts for something like 70 to 75% of
all healthcare spending in this country
do you feel like an insurer can really
sort of change that in some way that's
going to be meaningful yeah I mean when
you really look at what drives the cost
this is the crux of the issue and when
you look behind that there are many
behavioral related items that come into
play are people staying compliant with
their medication are people managing
smoking and weight and many other things
and so this is really a tough issue but
one of the ways that we have to look at
it is not just from a medical
perspective but what are the social and
behavioral elements of solving that
problem
so that goes back to working across all
the people that are giving care not even
in the traditional sense of of a medical
doctor but sometimes they're social
workers involved in other things well we
look at that in our models of managing
Medicaid or Medicare these issues are
incredibly relevant so again we believe
it's around aligning the incentives
bringing all the stakeholders to the
table having the integrated data as well
and understanding that it's a
combination of both the social
behavioral as well as medical issues
that we have to solve to solve that
problem for the long-term so could what
I call that a cautious yes we can change
this problem or we have to change this
problem and I think you know when you
look at our care more model in Medicare
it's demonstrated that we've been able
to reduce readmissions to hospitals
we've demonstrated that we've been able
to reduce the amount of diabetic
amputations real proven facts around
those topics so yes we absolutely have
to yes we will we have to and if we
don't address this chronic care issue
not only for Medicare and Medicaid but
across our our other lines of business
as well
we're not going to get at the ultimate
cost issue well Lori thank you so much
for sharing your insights on digital
transformation whether it's to be here
thank you Michael this is Michael
Fitzgerald with MIT Sloan management
review thank you for joining us for this
discussion on digital transformation and
we look forward to having you join us
for our next one